hanging out right now with Steve Smith
senior my compadre from the NFL Network
and NFL media group back on the NFL
Network and Fox coverage tonight what do
you think it will be like for Josh Allen
to walk into the Buffalo Bills locker
room after all those tweets and his
draft a rollercoaster Steve well you
gotta look at Millennials things are
different now
social media is such a huge part of
their lives they want to be influences
they want to be brands and all that
stuff so guys to the new guys understand
that the older guys are you know
retiring they're moving on so I think
he's gonna have someone's going to have
want to have a conversation with them
maybe want to ask him what content why
how and then when you look at some of
the tweets some of them are just songs
you know it's the song lyrics not saying
it's okay but at the same time when you
have that type of music have that those
type of words that everyone listens to
all shapes sizes color creed race and he
tweeted it probably shouldn't have
obviously yes but you know it's no
different than a black guy doing it you
know really you shouldn't do it either
way but that's what it is just speaking
as a dad right I'm not saying that
because the color his skin he should and
I'm just saying that's not what you're
supposed to put out there socially
anyway so would you suggest to him that
he address it first thing like call
people you know depends because you also
don't want to come across fake well I'm
sure he wants to put it to bed right
away I mean but here's the thing what
something's out people are gonna always
say something I'm on the I work with you
guys and I'm on the show you know we do
the good morning
you know good game day morning yeah I'm
on a East Coast team and I still hear
after it's been not almost it's been ten
years since I've had my incident someone
always says something
what about a fight yes are you gonna no
one with Sucker Punch today so it was a
good day for Steve Smith on TV people
are gonna say stuff I love when I see
you know someone says watching his show
Steve is awful
what are you watching it buddy yeah
right so that's just common I go slow I
mean that that's one thing of us being
in the public eye I'm talking about
inside his locker room he's they're
gonna have come they're gonna have
conversations got but they also gonna
who does he know who to have a
conversation with election LaShawn go up
to him or some a come up to him in there
they're gonna fill them out to to see
what kind of kid he is a good friend of
mine who I won't name he grew up he was
non African American grew up with Africa
with African American dues and he the
group's he was wet used the n-word
we got around them we looked at my Sabra
we said man cuz he was using it because
he was ingrained to use it yes okay so
you basically told him we can't one time
and no I did actually but the story came
he was like he was somewhere else he
said it and they were playing dominoes
and three of the dudes note or two dudes
at the Domino table stood up and one
other guy was like he doesn't know any
better
and so they had to have a conversation
with him he's like hey bro you can't
that's not acceptable you know yeah you
know I don't mean a laugh yeah but noise
but that those things happen and it just
it's living life so then do you think
because if let's put it this way I
didn't want to say this yesterday I
think it needs to be said though now
that we are 24 hours past that he's on a
team and and now we're in the stage of
him having to to deal with the
after-effects if somebody had this
information in his or her possession on
a team and made a reporter aware of
what's going on at the right time and
it's not the reporters fault this is
information and this is definitely
newsworthy material yeah if they
specifically from a team having this
information because they vetted Josh out
and hand it off like you know what
we haven't seen of this information out
and we're sitting there and say in the
teens and maybe we can get them let's
get it out there if that happens don't
you think the league should punish a
team for doing something like that
sometimes just I'm a player I played a
long time I ain't cheating you ain't
trying you love I tell you this my wife
is not the same shading of me
my kids are interracial mm-hmm my boys
look like me my daughter my little
princess looks like my wife I
specifically have had conversations with
my daughter when she gets her hair
pressed out she looks she's beautiful
all that stuff myself we tell her I've
told her multiple times the way you look
there are certain things that just can't
come out your mom sweetheart because the
way you look it's not going to be
accepted it's not going to be perceived
you've got to be seen not what the race
of your father is but what the race of
your mother is she got to be very
careful around certain folks how old is
she she's 16 and she understands that
and that's the facts that that is living
life and knowing how I know I've been
around here for a long time and knowing
how you are and how close you are with
your family and your wife what did you
make of the news that John Dorsey said
he did not share with his wife even his
wife the information of his cheesy first
overall that means he was he was keep
keeping that tight look with that fly in
the Smith household that's why he only
took that's why he only said hours
before so it doesn't he it has no
residual effect no residual effect yeah
but Steve maybe he should have told her
so she could have talked him out of it
because those were not some good picks
okay let's take a break we're back in 60
seconds with Steve Smith I want to hit
on lamar jackson and you've made some
notes about some of your thoughts about
the first round of the NFL Draft 84 for
204 rich those on Holtz they are noble
you're gonna take your calls before Jim
Brown arrives here on the Rich Eisen
show live from the NFL experience
[Music]
dez bryant may not be the only target
that Cowboys quarterback dak Prescott
loses this offseason Jason Witten the
perennial all-pro tight end may be
joining Monday Night Football 'z
broadcast crew as a lead analyst
according to multiple reports the
Cowboys tight end plans to meet today
with team owner Jerry Jones before
making his decision to retire final and
of course he would retire than begin his
broadcasting and career this fall 49ers
have traded offensive tackle Trent round
to the New England Patriots also a trade
between the Steelers and the Raiders
martavis Bryant headed from Pittsburgh
to Oakland and exchange for a
third-round pick and last night's a Quan
Barkley the Penn State running back was
selected second overall by the New York
Giants his pick generated more jersey
sales on draft night than any other
first-round pick top overall pick in
last night's draft was quarterback Baker
Mayfield he said under Cleveland Browns
I'm Deb Carson tomorrow settle in for an
afternoon of baseball on fs1 first the
Diamondbacks take on the Nationals then
the New York Yankees battle the LA
Angels it all begins tomorrow at 4:00
p.m. Eastern on FS 1
you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
we're here with Steve Smith senior
another segment with him before we we
then head into AT&T Stadium for the NFL
Draft the Honda Pilot inside a report is
what Steve Smith is bringing us right
now brought to you by the Honda dream
garage spring event the best part is
spring outside of baseball you can get a
great deal on the comfortable 2018 pilot
hurry into the Honda dream garage spring
event at your local Honda dealer uh
Lamar Jackson's drafting in Baltimore
yeah
many people say that's the end of Flacco
he's done or they say that he's going to
be done at some point in the near future
I think that the Ravens have done the
right thing they've done their due
diligence they went and got a very
talented player with a huge upside you
might be who knows he could be the next
to Shaun Watson they can get him in
there and he could start lighting it up
you never know but I think that they're
gonna have Flacco start this season and
they're gonna be a team that had despite
them saying he's a quarterback he's a
quarterback
we'll have since they are points
challenged yeah we'll have no choice but
to have a Lamar Jackson packaged and put
that in front of him would you agree
with that absolutely you you you can't
you can't have you can't have that nice
luxury car sitting in a garage on a nice
sunny day you got to take that thing up
standing there in a helmet and pads
because he's because he insists on being
a quarterback and that that's the
interesting thing is that if he even let
people know in Decatur I'd be willing to
have a package don't you think he might
even have been drafted higher last night
or no no I teams so teams have they go
through this process and they they love
and hate guys based on their needs and
sometimes people don't understand that's
available and the knee gets fickle din
the draft what the Baltimore Ravens did
with Lamar Jackson they say it like
every other team does we have an older
player
may not be performing to the expectation
that we would like and when that time
comes let's start to be ready and have a
guy step in line they do all y receivers
every year they do a linebackers they do
it with guards and tackles running backs
tight ends I can go through a plethora I
can go through all 20 to 22 positions
they do it every year we have seven
rounds they're not just teams don't pick
just one need and then they just kind of
all randomly it's all strategic you know
there's the bad teams that play checkers
the great teams continuously play chess
year in and year out it's interesting I
hear that all the time Marshall Michael
anybody that's not been a quarterback
why do they treat quarterbacks
differently why is it such a problem
there's opposition there so what do you
think Flacco is thinking this morning
knowing him as well as you do well he's
not easy his facial expression is not
going to change
samples he understands what's what's at
stake and that whole organization
understands what's at stake because they
are not this is organization for before
a couple years ago they're making a
playoffs every year they were in the
hunt they were being considered a team
that you need to be concerned about now
they are not that team anymore
pittsburgh has become that team New
England is that team now the question is
who is that next team looks like
Minnesota just all these different teams
are starting to present themselves as
viable playoff potential teams and the
Baltimore Ravens have slid and they want
to get back there what I believe is
interesting is what I tried talking
about last night is character constants
becoming a GM a new set of eyes when the
nuclear coach comes in you can guarantee
that he brings in his guys for his
philosophy what he wants and that's what
Eric is gonna do he's gonna bring in a
guy that sets him up Ozzie and all that
size you up to
do well but also Eric to have success so
moving forward as the gym you don't just
say hey you'll take your ball and run
right you leave it you put some get a
new tube and you know wash off the
sports cord and do it up and make sure
that you are setting it up for the next
guy to be successful do you think
there's any chance Steve Smith that
Lamar Jackson when placed with a 10-play
package where he's and shotgun and does
an RPO or where he's out wide that he
looks that and says I'm a quarterback no
thanks you think there's any chance of
that happening I think it can depends on
the play I've had plays where they've
asked me in multiple teams multiple
offerings coordinators and they say hey
we want you to run up a line and line up
and running back for what I'm a wider
throw me the ball
yeah well I don't line me up in but
you're Steve Smith yeah but I'm just
telling you him not running a forty says
look I'm a quarterback I don't want you
to know how fast I am because then
you're gonna get the idea of putting me
in a position that I don't want to play
understand but I mean we just agreed
that they need to have you can't have a
Ferrari in the garage
unless you sit in a nice Sun okay so
what you don't put that Ferrari in the
NASCAR race either right so what do you
do you put them in it because you you
let them play quarterback you allow him
to throw the ball so Flacco comes off
the field for a few plays okay that's
that's what that's why the business
aspect come are you gonna be a team
player that's just part of the gig man
that's part of the gig Steve Smith in
the Honda inside a report here on the
Rich Eisen show ok you've written down
some notes right there what left out are
you for the first round so Peter said
there's gonna be some I think some teams
that may get some quarterbacks in a
second third round their night tonight
there have been so many great there's so
many great defensive players that the
offensive players are getting really
pushed down yeah that happened last
night and and so Detroit has a
quarterback as he's pretty good but he's
getting older
you got a new new head coach he's gonna
want somebody to at least look at and
say hey what happens if that hand acts
up again what happens if he gets hurt
okay so you think the Lions might
for quarterback I'm saying 50/50 if they
get a guy that they've looked at as
possibly you know why not it's not gonna
hurt anything I mean it doesn't hurt the
when the stocks down and throw some
money in there and get it wise down is
it okay who else
chargers isn't that amazing last night
Eli
Big Ben and Phillip Rivers all dodged
the bullet but Flacco did not okay
intra Pittsburgh right Pittsburgh so
there's Big Ben you think they go they
go quarterback tonight potentially I
think so okay
New England yeah I'm hesitant to say
this but I want to say go for it Steve
Smith I believe they love them but I
wouldn't be surprised yes it possibly
eighty get somebody just in case the
Dallas Cowboy why not
why do you makes you think good here's
why starting quarterbacks good quarter
when you have a good quarterback yes
it's hard to find that's why that's why
the that's why people were pulling down
their pants to get them get these
quarterbacks in the draft right selling
it sell it selling all kind of stuff
rims yeah you know I was like going to
the barbershop in the hood they're
selling everything that this kind of
forget a guy that the next guy and
there's some next guy there's some next
guys in there that you can look at
doesn't if you drive for ganas in a
second and third round and he doesn't
pan out as a quarterback
what does it hurt nothing it wasn't like
he was going to play tomorrow anyway
mmm-hmm
but say he is there and something
happens there you go oh Allah Tom Brady
somebody it's the National Football
League
somebody's gonna trip on a rock and get
hurt that's just that's just what
happens before I let you go Steve let's
let's leak be good corporate people in
the NFL Network own
games two and three of Thursday Night
Football
before Fox simulcast of the NFL Network
there's two and if this two Thursday
night football games on the NFL Network
to kick-off the 2018 season I want you
to tell me your best guess who the
starting quarterbacks in this game are
going to be week one
I mean week two Thursday Night Football
yes so four days after week one Sunday
is over Ravens at Bengals we're the
starting quarterbacks in that game
Joe Flacco okay and don't ya Dalton
until something yeah okay but but but it
would be flat so it will be flat going
week to it I can it's gonna be Flacco
threw out this whole year okay Flacco is
the starting so you don't think there
could be a moment where where the memory
in in training camp and preseason
they're like huh
and that that made them pause and make a
move no okay what is gonna do the same
thing that happened with Alex hmm we
like where we see keep letting them
develop keep letting them develop okay
week three Jets at Browns who are the
starting quarterbacks week three the
veterans are the starting quarterbacks
Josh McCown yes versus Tyrod Taylor yes
it is here's here's why okay josh is a
really good friend of mine
josh has just as everything I'm not josh
is very sociable Johnson makes me
question why I'm not as sociable so he
just has that
but he's one of those guys walking like
man I need to be more like Josh Johnson
awesome Josh is a mentor Josh will give
you everything
Josh will give you the shirt on his back
he's a great he's a great coach he was
off his coordinator back at the high
school up there and Charlie he's a great
guy he's gonna mentor him and give him
everything he has cuz that's who Josh is
but he's not ready right now to Baker
Mayfield to be that guy okay and you
have to be very careful to throw a kid
in there and because he sees becomes
daring hairlines and when you get a guy
deer-in-headlights it's hard to change
that so tie-rod is gonna coach I ride it
will tie rod will coach him up Tyrus a
great guy - okay I was the one
unique thing about Tyrod that I love
watching Tyrone I was in Baltimore
he worked his butt off what he was at
Virginia Tech was a scrambling
quarterback right he threw the ball he
threw the ball pretty good
well how and what he worked on his game
when he was in Baltimore got him right
there he works on his game he works on
the touch he's gonna improve that young
man because he knows what it's like to
not feel wanted you know because that
can happen at times we had a backup we
in a back up you feel unwanted well
before I let you go when Darnell was
drafted I'm like here's a 20 year old
who's half the age of Josh McCown I said
that on the air last night as you heard
so then I come off the air cuz I'm off
Twitter during the broadcast cuz I don't
want it any pics tipped so Josh McCown
tweeted out last night since posting
text is a thing now here's one from my
oldest daughter after he drafted Sam
darn 'old the text from his daughter
says he's less than a year older than me
yes crazy and Josh responded wow thanks
bro
Bridget she's out of she's at Tennessee
and our two oldest are the same age and
that's crazy that's what she said yes
less than a year older than me crazy
that's how it is I had thanks for the I
had a guy told me in a locker room he
goes first you see I knew he was gonna
be a wise wise ass
he goes hey mr. Smith I said yes he goes
when you were drafted I was in the first
grade I say you officially made me feel
old who was it tell us who it was my it
was max from from Minnesota to tied-in
okay I can't remember Max's last name oh
that's a problem if we can't remember no
no because I've never when he called him
by his last name okay it was the tight
end for Minnesota that we drafted couple
years ago yeah great kid though
max Williams yes Williams there you go
two x's good to see you sir appreciate
it we'll see you later tonight yes sir
you're the man that Steve Smith right
here the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on